so what do you have yeah my question is
basically
recently on Facebook someone had posted
asking why are the effects of gravity
shown as a funnel if there's no up or
down and you had mentioned that at the
2d illustration of a four dimensional
phenomenon
I stock it a little
no it stalks anything a little bit but I
just answer that like yesterday or
something so thanks for checking it out
okay
so my question is just why then are
galaxies and solar systems disc-shaped
or on their own point excellent question
and that plagued philosophers for
centuries until the mid-1800s Immanuel
Kant mmm Immanuel Kant not at that and
that doesn't sound good at all
actually one of series replies on the
iPhone if you ask her Siri what is the
meaning of life she says I'm sorry I
can't answer that
yes so Immanuel Kant and a few others
tried to ask the question and answer the
question how is it that the entire solar
system the planets and the moons all
ordered in a plane and they orbit in the
same direction like what are the odds
yeah alright so what they had
prophesized was something called
literally the nebular hypothesis which
has borne out in open the centuries of
observations and data that we've taken
since then and basically start out with
a massive gas cloud and then it
collapses as you collapse use begin to
spin faster this is like what happens
with a skater draws in his or her arms
what happens when that happened they
spin that's what happens so as you spin
faster in the plane of that spinning the
material can't fall in because like the
centrifugal forces prevent that right
okay technically there's centripetal yes
so so in the
the axes in the sort of equator of the
spinning it can't come in because of
these centripetal forces okay but top to
bottom it can collapse without
hesitation so what you get is a
flattened disc that where everything is
warbling in the same direction all night
God that makes
its own event so this dude figured this
out in the middle of 1800s and it's been
working ever since now suppose suppose
you are moving very slowly in this and
you're not collapsing quickly you can
actually form stars that don't actually
collapse into a disk if you form start
the reason why it sticks to a disk it's
because it's made of mostly gas right at
the beginning and gas can't pass through
itself any more than one hot marshmallow
can pass through another hot marshmallow
what happens when two hot marshmallows
hit you get a bigger hot marshmallow
yes if they stick and become a big one
so so when you have a gas cloud
collapsing it sticks to itself in the
plane and it doesn't collapse within the
plane it stays flat everything else
collapse pancake style too do you know
our our galaxy is flatter than a pancake
is this flat is a crepe
galaxy bunch we're a hundred thousand
light years across and about a hundred
light years thick so we are a thousand
to one ratio thickness to diameter well
and that's basically a crazy say yeah
it's a lot of math it's not a pancake on
it yes okay we need them so so cat yo
came you what we square
yeah that was great
mine should be blown daily yes so have
some galaxy for breakfast tomorrow every
time I eat a crepe I think of our galaxy
that's awesome you guys thanks cat